sin duda la economía y la gestión de la
pandemia son una gran preocupación cuál
es el camino que a su juicio debería
tomar quien llegue a la jefatura de
estado para mitigar está castigada de
economía ecuatoriana
buenos días si digamos que el principal
reto al que se enfrente se enfrentaría
el presidente electo es justamente
empezar una campaña de vacunación no en
esta economía tan deprimida y de eso
dependerá digamos yo creo que el triunfo
el éxito por lo menos en los primeros
100 días de gobierno por decir algo no y
luego las medidas económicas para salir
de esta grave crisis no tenemos dos
opciones o digamos tres opciones o tres
modelos que se han planteado el retorno
alcoholismo una nueva derecha que no ha
estado en el poder y la opción del
movimiento indígena que vuelve para
cuestionarla la izquierda conservadora
no que representa el correísmo con
nuevas propuestas para salir de la
crisis
bueno hablemos hoy precisamente de eso
otro de los puntos en la mira es el ex
presidente rafael correa que apoyó al
candidato araus que le espera ecuador si
vuelve a la senda de correa
bueno le espera un retorno bastante
complejo no un ambiente de venganza que
es la que es el tinte no del correísmo
una venganza de todo lo que en el
gobierno de lenin moreno se avanzó
respecto a la revisión de el desmontaje
de un sistema estructurado de corrupción
montado desde el estado en los 10 años
del correísmo una fuerte tensión de
venganza y sobre todo retomar las formas
de gobierno que haremos parece
digamos parece abanderar y con los que
parece simpatizar lo que sólo espera el
ecuador y una oposición un país
altamente dividido entre una derecha que
se articula atrás del lazo y una
izquierda que ha sido acostada hostigada
perseguida durante los 10 años del
correísmo que ahora está más articulada
y más fortalecida por el retorno de
pachakutik con un candidato fuerte bueno
sofía y hablemos ahora del legado del
presidente de lenin moreno que debe
continuar y que no
bueno el legado del presidente del rey
moreno es en primer instancia tratar de
desmontar una estructura corrupta una
estructura altamente perjudicial para el
estado así que dio al traste con la
oportunidad de salir y salir de algunos
de algunas marcas algunas marcas
históricas del país con los 10 años de
bonanza sin embargo no se hizo
lenin moreno sin embargo se aplazó se
aplazó en desmontar de verdad lo que fue
el régimen digamos de estructura
correísta quedaron muchos muchos legados
todavía y se aplazó sobre todo en la
ejecución ejecución de nuevas políticas
la activación de un nuevo gobierno que
dé esperanza para marcar un nuevo camino
entonces yo creo que por eso por eso nos
encontramos en la disyuntiva hoy de un
retorno bastante grave para el país sin
haber logrado a generar un camino nuevo